[Musique]
et
qui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bonjour à tous
bienvenue sur ce live en collaboration
avec la fnac et sony je suis aujourd'hui
avec jean denis favier salut jean denis
ça lui aurait bien
tuvalu m'accueillir bah écoute bienvenue
à la maison théâtre je lis tu es le
premier à venir dans le nouveau studio
on en reparlera plus tard donc pour
l'instant on regarde un petit peu le
suspense aujourd'hui on est là pour
parler d'audio vous l'avez compris on
est là pour parler des nouveaux
écouteurs de sony sont les w f 1000 x n
4 alors avant de parler un petit peu du
nom et de tout ça sachez qu'on est là
pendant allez on va se dire 20 25
minutes une des meilleures 40 minutes en
fonction de vous en fonction de vos
questions parce que les questions vous
pouvez les poser aussi bien sur mac
shane youtube vous avez le chat vous y
allez vous posez vos questions
mais bien évidemment sur le site de la
fnac vous avez un chat qui est là
également à votre disposition donc à vos
claviers
pendant toute la durée du live vous
pouvez vous pouvez poser toutes vos
questions
il ya un jean denis qui est l'expert qui
saura vous répondre j'essaierai de
répondre à peut-être quelque chose on
verra si jamais j'ai des compléments
d'information mais c'est vraiment lui
experts de sony alors on va dans un
premier temps essayé de parler de sony
je pense que tout le monde connaît se
niche parce que je n'imagine pas qu'elle
est quelques-uns qui ne connaissent pas
encore sony aujourd'hui sony c'est un
incontournable c'est un mastodonte et
sony 1 à stowe don dans l'univers du
cinéma et de la production vous avez des
studios vous avez des télé pour regarder
il ya des consoles de jeux
il y a d'la musique mais également et
sony vous est également présent dans les
oreilles de beaucoup de monde qui
veulent écouter de la musique se faire
plaisir
tu peux me parler un petit peu de sony
parce que c'est tellement de choses à
dire tu l'as déjà pas mal pas mal
dégrossi aujourd'hui sony est à une
société japonaise basée à tokyo qui fête
d'ailleurs ses 75 ans cette année
d'existence donc une société ancienne et
qui est donc spécialisée dans le domaine
de l'électronique et du divertissement
et donc comme tu le mentionner
aujourd'hui sony va couvrir l'ensemble
du processus de création de contenu que
ce soit de la partie cinéma avec sony
pictures sony music le label
donc voilà pour soutenir tous les atouts
les artistes et soit une partie après
+10 vice et la maison donc les télés les
casques l'idée étant d'être au départ la
création de contenus et donc l'écouter
ou le regarder chez soi avec des
produits qui soient
qu'ils soient la pointe de la
technologie comme c'est petit et coûteux
à installer une caméra tac on switch
alors ces petits écouteurs on va sans
parler alors avant toute chose avant
toute chose jean-denis y ait un truc est
très important c'est le nom et chez sony
les noms on aime bien se faire un petit
peu mal si ici la référence la nouvelle
référence qu'on la voit bien c'est la wf
1000 x n 4 est ce que tu peux
m'expliquer le nom dégâts pour qu'on
comprenne pour que le consommateur
puisse comprendre on allait on a t'on
casque là par exemple à ce que tu peux
le montrer lui c'est le w h 1000 x n 4
on est le w h 1000x m3 sa génération
d'avant limbé sur le wf 1000x m 4 et
puis il ya eu il ya deux ans c'était pas
de bêtises le wf 1000x m3 alors un pour
vous expliquer un petit peu le la
jeunesse de tous à la famille 1000x chez
sony représentent ce que sony sait faire
de mieux en terme de qualité de son et
de réduction de bruit on a d'abord
démarré avec les w/h 1000x donc c'est la
gamme de casque arceau ya de cela quatre
ans une gamme qu'on a fait évoluer année
après année jusqu'à la version 4 whl x
mark iv qu'on a lancé l'an dernier et
qui est la référence aujourd'hui sur le
marché en termes de réduction de bruit
dans un format arceaux et comme tu le
disait fort justement il ya deux ans on
a lancé les wf minix martroi qui étaient
les premiers écouteurs sans fil avec une
réduction de bruit active efficace
performante à l'intérieur et fort
logiquement après le 3 on à leucate donc
qui lui succède aujourd'hui donc les wf
1000 x mark iv c'est quand qu'on prend
très très bien le mark 4 mark iii et
puis ça ça me rappelle vraiment la photo
de ce qu'on peut retrouver chez certains
fabricants et w ça veut dire quoi w fwh
tu sais ou pas alors le w c pour
wireless on est sur une gamme de
produits qui est qui et sans fil
le h pour la partie est de bandes en
anglais donc casque à arceau et le f
pour la partie écouteurs sans fil va
venir proposer la partie freedom liberté
de mouvement aux quais génial qu'on va
avoir des écouteurs 100% sans fil alors
ce qui est super génial enfin je bosse
aussi génial que c'est super intéressant
on le voit alors là on a bien la
référence du produit quand on loue on
voit 1000 x series ça veut donc dire
qu'en fait la partie w mwh an son fils
un petit peu le vrai la vraie
dénomination en fait c'est 1000 x series
ben disons qu'au début on a démarré avec
un modèle qui était le double mdr 1000 x
et les années dans le succès aidant on a
vraiment créé toute une gamme de
produits que ce soit des écouteurs sans
fil des tours de nuque des casque arceau
et donc c'est qu'aujourd'hui comme tu le
comme celle mentionnée on a vraiment une
série 1000 x
donc on retrouve là sur le sur le
packaging d'ailleurs c'était assez
intéressant je sais pas s'ils ont pu
revenir
monsieur on peut si hollywood ici voilà
c'est comme ça
donc là on le voit peut-être un petit
peu à l'écran mais on est sur un
packaging qui assez particulier un
matériau assez particulière on est sur
du un assemblage de papier recyclé de
bambous et de fibre de canne à sucre
qu'on est sur un packaging qui est
respectueux de l'environnement très
compact à l'image du produit qu'il y
avait juste à côté donc on est vraiment
dans l'idée de se dire ok produits
éco-responsables emballages éco
responsable exit les plastiques on fait
attention on fait attention pour la
planète c'est quelque chose qui est
importante chez sony c'est exactement ça
fait partie d'une démarche globale au
niveau 2 du groupe du groupe sony de
toujours s'inscrire dans une logique de
protection de l'environnement de
s'améliorer année après année est donc
là en l'occurrence sur ses options ce
produit là
il ya un pas qui est fait notamment donc
au niveau de ce packaging qui est 100%
recyclé un hockey et c'est super
intéressant alors je veux qu'on parle
des produits parce que c'est
effectivement ce qui nous intéresse on
est venu ici on a un beau packaging
c'est génial maintenant je veux que tu
me parles du wf me dis que c'est
peut-être alors y'a plein de points à
regarder tellement ce ce ce casque c'est
parce qu'à ses écouteurs sont écouteurs
cc oui je bug tellement quelque chose
les casques ont cité un petit peu ces
écouteurs sont super intéressant je vous
ai fait d'ailleurs une vidéo sur youtube
je sais pas si vous l'avez regardé moi
j'adore très honnêtement j'adore il faut
d'abord restituer le prix pour qu'on
comprenne de quoi on parle on parle ici
de premium on parle d'écouteurs
extrêmement prégnante à un petit peu
moins de 280 euros
aujourd'hui voilà 280 euros on a ce qui
se fait de mieux sur le marché en termes
de réduction de bruit et de qualité de
son dans un dans un format très compact
qu'on peut emmener partout avec soi
glisser dans sa poche et un peu plus
développée par par la suite mais il ya
beaucoup de choses effectivement dans ce
dans ce petit produire alors ce qui est
super intéressant c'est qu'il ya une
différence de deux formats par rapport
au mark iii de l'année dernière qui
était un poil plus large là on est plus
sur une forme j'ai l'impression de bugs
un petit peu plus standard quelques on
peut le retrouver à la concurrence
quelle est l'idée justement d'avoir
réduit cette forme est ce que c'est
quelque chose qui plaisait un petit peu
moins est ce que c'est pour rentrer dans
des codes un peu plus classique du
marché pourquoi l'idée en fait avec
cette date cette dernière cette dernière
version
c'est d'avoir un produit toujours plus
compacts parce qu'aujourd'hui les gens
aiment avoir un produit qui les
accompagne tout au long de la journée
l'idée c'est qu'ils glissent partout
avec soi dans la dans la poche voilà
sans prendre trop de place donc c'est
d'ailleurs l'idée qu'on a quand on voit
le boîtier aujourd'hui à l'écran donc un
boîtier qui est très compact qui fait
grosso modo le gabarit d'une clé d'une
telle voiture
donc voilà on peut mettre dans sa poche
sans problème est ailleurs
là on peut on peut noter un mail et les
finitions qui sont plutôt haut de gamme
avec du noir mat sur sur le boîtier la
petite le logo qui apparaît sur le
dessus en cuivre et well as sur la
livrée la livre et argent en doré et qui
reprend en fait les codes esthétiques
présent déjà sur la famille la famille
arceaux ans que j'ai ici donc du douar
maths et les finitions également cuivré
ou doré selon le selon le coloris c'est
la même chose on retrouve vraiment
l'école il ya deux couleurs ici en fait
il n'a pas plusieurs y en a juste 2 elle
brille était simplissime piété qui pas
forcément avec le segment le segment
haut de gamme et donc voit cette logique
en fait deux compacts de compacité
pardon on va la retrouver au niveau d d
d écouteurs way qui sont aussi en fait
les voir ces écouteurs très peu sort les
de la boîte qu'on les voit bien j'espère
qu'on les voit bien la camair-co bien
essayer de viser alors attendre voilà
lève un peu la main on est on ne prenait
pas dessus je vous dis tout de suite on
est en train d'être à plat on met la
main à plat on fait le point
le point vient vers moi le point devient
pas à l'organe j'ai une méthode quand le
point devient pas tu appuies sur les
caméras mais thorgan au centre c'est du
direct à vous le voyez c'est
complètement du direct est ce que ça
veut servent à l'essai dubaï fourni et
bravo génial génial mal donc on a
vraiment des des petits écouteurs avec
une lan le voit une grande une grande
surface en fait quelle surface tactile
contre à droite et à gauche pour piloter
l'ensemble des commandes du de la
musique des appels de la réduction de
riggs ouais on a également des micro
qu'on peut déjà noter ici j'ai passé un
petit micro sur le côté en fait là on le
voit n'est pas rose voilà on en a la
géniale il y en a également à ici il ya
six micros du coup en tout 20 sur les
deux écouteurs way qui vont avoir donc
un des fonctions sur la réduction de
bruit sur la qualité des appels on y
reviendra après mais voilà donc
effectivement des petits pains produit
qui est qui est très compact qui se
rendent directement donc dans le dans le
petit boîtier de manière les ventes et
donc voilà ça tient bien c'est vrai ça
je le prends je le mets dedans il trouve
sa place tout de suite ça c'est super
pratique
donc c'est génial enrayer un truc moi
qui m'interpelle et j'avais trouvé ça
super intéressant contre les ai
découverts ce sont les petits en bout
j'ai l'impression que c'est différent
tu peux me raconter l'histoire des
embouts parce que ça en terme de confort
et d'expérience c'est extrêmement
important le fait d'avoir des embouts
qui viennent déjà bien
trouver leur forme qui viennent jouer
sur l'isolation facile mais s'en va en
parler dans quelques instants
ils sont différents c'est en bout par
rapport à ce qu'on retrouve dans le
marché c'est qu'en général sur le marché
on va retrouver deux types d'embouts on
va retrouver des embouts en silicone et
des embouts en mousse à mémoire de forme
est effectivement tu viens de mentionner
ces ambulances sont très particulières
parce qu'on vient inaugurer ici des
embouts en mousse de polyuréthane
d'accord d'interio qui est très
particulier sera compliqué de vous le
montrer peut être aujourd'hui à la
caméra mais c'est en gros un agglomérat
met toi bien au centre par la hausse
entre c'est la voie la méthode et le
centre comme ça c'est parfait 3 le point
juste là voilà voilà
yes stop ok donc voilà on est sur une
mousse en polyuréthane donc il ya plein
plein plein de petites billes qui vont
venir en fait prendre les bruits
environnants et après les dispatcher
entre elles pour venir assurer déjà une
très bonne isolation passive est
effectivement autre point positif c'est
le confort à l'usagé parce que on va
venir presser la mousse avant de le
mettre dans le dans le conduit auditif
et ça va venir prendre tout de suite la
forme du conduit auditif
donc ça va assurer une très bonne
adhérence
un très bon fit et on pourra porter du
coup les écouteurs de manière d'ailleurs
prolongé sans avoir peur également qu'il
tombe quand on secoue la tête par
exemple quand on est en mouvement
oui parce qu'en fait l'intérêt c'est
vraiment ça c'est que ça a bien retrouvé
la forme de votre oreille
vu qu'il reprend sa position naturelle
exact ça c'est génial alors donc on a un
vrai confort et ça c'est un truc que
j'aime vraiment remarqué lormontais
c'est qu'effectivement on les prend aux
il faut pas que je les perds quand même
291 204 euros oreilles ça serait un peu
ballot mais ça tient vraiment bien alors
du coup pour le point complet sur le
sujet mais dans le dans le dans le
packaging on va retrouver différentes
tailles ouais on va démontrer ici donc
directement montés sur le produit on a
une taille m l'on va retrouver une pièce
intel une taille l impôt vraiment
s'adapter à tous les types fétide
d'oreille d'ailleurs on va pouvoir aussi
bénéficier d'une assistance pour choisir
la bonne taille d'embouts dans
l'application saunier de faune connect
qui l'application compagnon du produit
qui permet de le paramétrer et de
vraiment faire un produit un produit sur
mesure
ouais et voilà donc l'application va
pouvoir nous nous guider et nous dire
quelles tailles d'embouts mètres à la
fois à gauche et à droite pour assurer
le meilleur le meilleur fit ainsi que la
meilleure isolation passive d'accord
donc c'est vraiment cool alors tiens tu
m'a lancé la perche par mois de
l'application par cette application elle
est hyper importante alors gelé connu
déjà on la connaissait déjà avec
notamment les w/h 1000x m3000 x n 4 les
noms sont compliquées on s'accroche on
va y arriver il a montré la pluie parce
que la pluie allait vraiment super bien
faite il ya un équaliseur c'est très
complet et c'est vraiment un truc qui
est complètement génial alors fait voir
l'apli c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui on à
l'application la plus complète du marché
on va pouvoir venir jouer sur la qualité
de son sur la réduction de bruit est
vraiment plein de paramètres
donc je mette un écouteur allez hop il
se connecte directement sa garde et on y
est est en direct
hop là
on se remet en plein écran connexion
allez on est parti on est parti pendant
ce temps là je voulais poser vos
questions on va pouvoir y répondre bien
évidemment que ce soit sur le site de la
fnac
que ce soit directement sur ma chaîne
youtube on diffuse des deux côtés on est
un petit peu partout donc profitez-en
posez toutes vos questions et on va
prendre un petit moment dans quelques
instants pour regarder à droite à gauche
on est connecté tout est ok c'est parti
en vivant alors vas-y montre moi cette
appli parce qu'elle est vraiment
vraiment super bien
donc quand on arrive de si on a
directement pas mal d'informations qui
apparaît sur le sur le premier écran
donc on va retrouver les écouteurs avec
notamment le niveau de batterie
individuelle à la fois à gauche à droite
la batterie également le niveau de
batterie pour pour le boîtier on y
reviendra après l' autonomie globale du
produit
on a le nom du produit qui s'affiche en
haut également le type de codec utilisé
donc là en l'occurrence vu qu'on va
venir ce prioriser la qualité de son
ouais on va notamment utilisé un codec
assez particulier qui le hell d'ac
wen a viendra on y reviendra après et
après en dessous on va pouvoir venir
jouer sur notamment ce qu'on appelle le
contrôle adaptatif du son ça veut dire
gérer la réduction de bruit en fonction
de mon activité ou de ma localisation et
donc comme vous pouvez voir ici il ya
tout une toute une série de documents
qu'on va pouvoir venir cochet paramétré
en fonction de nos usages pour vraiment
se faire une expérience sur mesure en
fonction de ses besoins
d'accord donc ça veut dire que je prends
une question d' usage par exemple je
suis dans le bus je peux me dire que
dans le bus se maintient je vais être
complètement fermés parce que je
pourrais y être embêté mais pour autant
je les ai je suis dans la rue je vais
être un peu plus attentif parce qu'on
sait jamais si je traverse une voiture
quelqu'un m'appelle quoi que ce soit je
peux venir moduler sa directement il
paramétrait dans mon application en fait
l'application va utiliser le gyroscope
du téléphone auquel va en fait détecter
l'activité de la personne donc si vous
êtes en train de marcher si vous êtes
dans les transports si vous êtes à
l'arrêt et en fonction des réglages que
vous aurez décidé la réduction de bruit
va automatiquement s'adapter donc par
exemple si je suis à l'arrêt dans une
gare et que je veux entendre une annonce
qui est qui est fait c'est tout à fait
possible du coup de gérer cette
réduction de bruit d'avoir un focus
également sur sur les voies pour ne pas
manquer l'annoncent 2
2 montre donc c'est vraiment très
pratique hyper pratique voilà ok donc ça
c'est pour la partie réduction bruit
alors moi je veux qu'on parle de
réductions bruit parce que c'est un
sujet qui est extrêmement importants et
d'autant plus avec un produit comme
celui là vous avez deux types de
réduction de bruit de la première c'est
la réduction de bruit passive qui peut
standard ce qui nous intéresse vraiment
ici c'est la réduction relative est
alors j'ai vu qu'en plus de ça je vais
retrouver je vais tout vous dire il ya
une étude
une étude qui était mené par sony
corporation le 26 avril 2020 il faut
être extrêmement précis attention on est
pressé ici conformément aux directives
de la jetta je ne sais pas ce que c'est
mais ça me va sur le marché les
écouteurs en fait vous êtes la meilleure
réduction de bruit du marché sur ce type
d'écouteurs ok ça veut dire quoi
aujourd'hui en 2021 est la meilleure
réduction louis sur le marché au niveau
des d'intras comme ça alors aujourd'hui
c'est que le ce produit proposer ce qui
se fait de mieux en termes de réduction
de bruit la réduction de prix pour ceux
encore qui ne qui ne sont pas familiers
avec ce concept là l'idée avec cette
fonctionnalité là ça va être de se
couper des des bruits ambiants d'être
dans une dans une bulle pour profiter de
sa musique sans être sans être dérangé
comment ça comment ça fonctionne on va
voir des micros à telle heure on les
montre et un petit peu d'introduction à
des micros directement sur le produit
qui viennent capter les les sons
environnants à l'intérieur on a un
processeur qui va analyser ces bruits et
derrière les restituer afin de les
annuler directement dans dans l'oreille
donc ça c'est la réduction de bruit ce
qu'on appelle active et à l'heure donc
ce qu'on a déjà commencé un petit peu a
discuté c'est la partie isolation
passive avec les avec les embouts donc
on ad'abord l'isolation passive
d'accord ça de bouche les oreilles en
fait physique voilà qui va venir bloquer
physiquement les les bruits environnants
et derrière ça on à la partie donc
actives numérique avec les micros le
processeur pour prévenir annulé le
maximum de bruit et pour profiter de sa
musique tout en toute tranquillité et
c'est vrai que ça marche bien
très honnêtement ça marche très très
bien on a une super bonne réduction
alors moi j'ai testé en avion j'ai testé
dans le train j'ai testé un peu partout
en baladant et c'est vrai que c'est pas
extrêmement bluffant que ça marche
vraiment vraiment bien en termes de
réduction de bruit alors on parle de
réduction de bruit ça c'est une très
très bonne chose d'autant ce qui nous
intéresse c'est effectivement la qualité
audio en termes de qualité audio alors
est ce que tu peux raconter un petit peu
l'histoire ya tout qui m'avait vraiment
santé quand on en avait parlé il ya vait
savez quand on
une marque lance un produit qui font
souvent ce qu'on appelle des prêts brief
avant même que le produit sur le marché
la presse est là on écoute on discute et
on nous dit voilà ce qu'on fait vous
vous avez des drivers de 6 mm
aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu plus la
course à venir augmenter un petit peu la
taille pour potentiellement augmenter la
qualité en tout cas ce qui est souvent
entendu vous c'est pas le cas vous dites
on reste sur du 6 mm on le maîtrise ça
marche bien
derrière on a un processeur qui
fonctionne en fait c'est que tu as
plusieurs tas plusieurs éléments et donc
effectivement ce qu'on est venu faire
sur ce produit là c'est avant tout donc
travailler sur la qualité
un duo parleur l'idée n'est pas
forcément de faire du proposer du 10 12
mm on arrive à proposer un son haute
résolution avec un haut-parleur de 6 mm
donc très compact mais un son de un son
de qualité et ça n'aura pas échappé mais
le produit donc est certifié à iraizoz
diot donc pour ceux qui sonnent par la
radio wireless employeurs laisse
exactement donc le produit certifié
audio haute résolution c'est le premier
dans le genre dans l'univers des
écouteurs 100% sans fil on voyait déjà
sur la partie casque à casque arceau
mais c'est une première dans des formes
un format trous trous ailleurs les
écouteurs 100% sans fil on voit une
vraie qualité de son derrière ça
forcément donc le disais il ya le
processeur aussi qui vient travailler
sur sur cette qualité de son et une
amplification en 24 bits qui qui est
fait il alors ça c'est ce que tu peux
permettre de couper parce que c'est vrai
que pour le commun des mortels 24 bits
sa part tu as forcément
est ce que tu peux expliquer un petit
peu ce que ça veut dire ça en réalité
pour comprendre en quoi ça apporte une
bonne qualité audio le volcanique qu'est
ce que c'est
bah en fait le 24 bits ça va permettre
de travailler un échantillonnage qui est
beaucoup plus élevé par rapport à ce que
tu as une source en source d'arriver
dans l'est dans les écouteurs et
restituer une super qualité de son par
rapport à ce que tu avais
dans le haut niveau du téléphone
typiquement hockey top
donc ça c'est le processeur le même
processeur qui vient travailler sur la
rive sans bruit de processeurs v1 qui a
un processeur qui est développée
spécifiquement par par sony et donc il
va venir travailler à ce niveau là donc
il ya processeur on a parlé également du
haut parleur est également aussi la
méthode de transmission de données entre
le
le smartphone et les écouteurs et donc
en l'occurrence ici on a le lda qu'un
qui permet de transmettre trois fois
plus de données que du bluetooth
traditionnel une qualité de son haute
résolution
alors après il faut avoir le smartphone
qui va mais derrière contre l'écouté
accros au smart phone parce que des
smartphones android la plupart vont
avoir du hell d'ac mais si on est sur un
iphone on n'a pas de lda qu'on est sur
du harass et assez qui est aussi présent
du coup avec ce produit le sbc et le
hell d'ac maintenant qui est voilà
effectivement on ne peut pas très
répandu aujourd'hui dans le milieu de
téléphonie au kenya donc on sait qu'en
terme de qualité on est ce qu'il faut en
terme de connexion bluetooth ça marche
très très bien alors moi je veux tu me
parles d'une techno qui s'appelle c'est
certifié 360 reality audio qu'est ce que
c'est que ce truc là
alors le 360 qualité audio c'est c'est
une expérience sonore qui a été qui a
été lancé il ya déjà deux ans de ça en
collaboration notamment avec avec sony
music et l'idée donc c'est de proposer
une expérience totalement immersive
englobante et devenir positionner le son
des instruments ou alors la voix du
chanteur tout autour de soi vraiment
avoir une expérience de son de son
spatial ok donc s'attendait en fait dans
l'univers tu rentres vraiment plus dans
le concert par exemple
exactement en fait c'est comme si on
écoutait la musique directement dans le
studio d'enregistrement avec l'artiste
ou alors sur scène avec lui durant un
concert live
c'est un privilège aujourd'hui les
concerts c'est plutôt limité donc si
vous habitez de l'expérience concert
vous pouvez la retrouver du cou avait
mal compris comme si vous voulez
profiter d'un bon concert regardez vous
avez tous ici comme ça ça fonctionne
d'ailleurs ce produit s'il vous
intéresse bien évidemment il est en
vente vous en douterez si vous regardez
ce live depuis le site de la fnac et
bien vous y allez vous pouvez y aller
pouvez le commander alesi directement et
puis si vous êtes sur ma chaîne youtube
vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description vous cliquez et vous serez
redirigé bien évidemment sur le site de
la fnac donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
si vous voulez vous faire plaisir
il ya une techno s'appelle l'ops kaylin
fait de l'ops killing avec le drs e
extrême alors le ds extrême c'est un
traitement numérique qui va venir comme
on dit dans le jargon abscons et les
leçons c'est à dire qui va venir
améliorer des fichiers qui sont
transmises via le bluetooth donc ils
sont compressés avec une perte de
données donc ce traitement numérique va
venir travailler à ses fichiers pour
restaurer la qualité de son une fois une
fois que ça arrive dans votre
dans votre oreille ok avec notamment un
traitement très particulier sur sur les
aigus est ce ce ds eux
xtreme est le fruit du hasard d'un
travail avec avec sony music
donc forcément on fait en profitent des
synergies du groupe
il va être capable notamment de
reconnaître les types de les types de
musique les instruments pour venir
restituer le maximum de choses une fois
dans une fois dans l'oreille ok on a
deux trois questions on va commencer à
regarder un peu les questions avant de
continuer parler d'autonomie parce que
vous allez voir c'est super intéressant
une question qui nous est posée sur le
site de la fnac ça donne quoi en
comparaison avec les erp oates pro sexe
est souvent intéressant côtoient des
consommateurs on va regarder ce qui se
passe un petit peu à la concurrence
comment est ce que vous vous situez par
rapport à ce produit justement
alors aujourd'hui le tir et l'argument
premier 1 du double f mix market dont la
cité tout à l'heure et c'est celle une
étude externe c'est aujourd'hui la
meilleure réduction bruit du marché si
c'est la première chose ok la deuxième
chose également c'est la qualité de son
donc sony l'estonie doublet phoenix mark
iv e seront seront certifiés à erez aéré
audio wireless pour être tout à fait
tout à fait complet et on l'a vu tout à
l'heure déjà donc on n'a pas fait toutes
les fonctionnalités mais on a déjà vu un
aperçu il ya l'application compagnon qui
permet de paramétrer dans tous les sens
le produit pour vraiment avoir une
expérience sur mesure donc c'est quelque
chose de possible avec avec notre modèle
hockey iliad ghazi qui nous dit sur
youtube qui n'était pas forcément
satisfait du confort des marques 3
est-ce que seul ceux ci sont plus
confortable par rapport aux marques 3
comme une différence significative
justement au niveau des ombres et du
confort global il ya plusieurs heures il
ya plusieurs éléments la première chose
donc on a vu tout à l'heure c'est le
c'est le type d'embouts utilisez donc
qui apporte un meilleur confort un
meilleur fit une meilleure stabilité
dans l'oreille on a vu qu'il y avait
également un travail sur sur les sur les
écouteurs et qui sont beaucoup plus
compact qui dépasse moins de l'oreille
donc ce qui permet d'avoir moins cet
effet de balancier vers vers l'extérieur
qui a engagé en termes de en termes de
design
voilà il ya un vrai effort qui a été
fait également termes de poids parce que
maintenant on est aux alentours de 7
grammes pour par écouteurs donc c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment très légers tels
qu'on les sent pas dans les oreilles et
il sait combien les bac 3 ou pas tu sais
ou par 10 était à + de vie g baca un
régime préfet est ce à ce niveau la
musique du chipotage à ce prix là quand
on commence à me g 100 g
moi je pense que je suis incapable de
sentir la différence de 1 g voire 2 g
dans mes oreilles
je pense que pour certains après une
utilisation poussée sur plusieurs heures
dit d'accord ça peut jouer mais
effectivement ce que sera ce comme des
produits qui sont très compact et très
léger
tu nous parlais d'application est ce
qu'on peut revenir un peu sur cette
application parce qu'elle est
extrêmement complète et notamment ça
c'est vraiment génial alors attendez que
le temps qu'on se reconnaître regardez
il faut le faire on se fait ça en direct
a repris en mai dans les oreilles en
trek parce que vous allez voir est riche
il n'ya pas de triche
et y'a pas du filet donc si on fait une
bêtise en là on l'a directement ce que
je trouve qui est vraiment intéressant -
ici c'est toute la partie et coalisation
qui est extrêmement pertinente pour
pouvoir effectivement profité d'une
d'une superbe expérience
ça c'est très très très cool il ya pas
mal de petites choses qu'on peut venir
régler directement ici en france connect
regarder on se met comme ça on est en
train de se connecter nous voilà alors
je fais un petit peu de classe fait de
la place calme hhk grandi comme ça on
voit tout alors on a différentes parties
on voit qu'on a et à la première partie
état où on va venir voir effectivement
et bien si on est connecté le contrôle
d'appétit chez compagnie voilà également
la partie et la partie musique pour
piloter sa musique
ouais quant à la partie sans on va
pouvoir tenir venir régler la réduction
de bruit le niveau de réduction de bruit
sur près de 20 niveaux donc si on a
vraiment une réduction de bruit qui est
qui ajustable qui est une manière très
tard ce qui est génial c'est éric
champoux tu peut effectivement dire ben
joue un petit peu de réduction bruit
mais exactement et je l'a carrément le
max ça que dans le voit même bien sûr
l'application mais plus je vais vers la
droite et plus je vais me connecter au
web qui m'entourent donc les bruits de
personnes
passants dans la rue les bruits de
voitures qui passent donc ça c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment top
si je reviens sur la partie réduction de
bruit on note également qu'on peut jouer
sur le bruit du vent c'est quelque chose
qui est souvent très désagréable ok
quand on a des écouteurs à réduction de
bruit d'un coup même un casque un voile
sombre sur le sur les oreilles les
micros extérieur qui savent elles
arrivent sont nourris sont souvent gênés
par par le vent et donc ce produit en
l'occurrence va détecter quand il ya un
vent fort pour désactiver les micros
pour éviter ces deux gènes durant
l'écoutons ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment très pratique
alors moi il ya un truc que je te le dis
je pense que ça ne sert pas grand chose
c'est le speak to chat le par les pans
de châtel et ça c'est un truc a été
lancé et dernière avec les mâles et w h
mais le mix market effective moi j'ai
beaucoup mais en fait pour vous
expliquer la fonctionnalité vous avez
votre casque d'écouté de la musique vous
arriver je sais pas dans un jeu par les
stars des hawks par exemple à starbucks
vous avez vous dit bonjour je voudrais
un café ainsi et ça et ça reconnaît que
vous parlez du coup sa coupe la musique
ça active les micros pour pouvoir capter
le son extérieur et vous allez pouvoir
converser soit avec un casque dans le
cadre du w h 1104 soit avec vos
écouteurs dans le cas des wf melix m4s
que c'est une question sociale peut-être
ça fonctionne mais je suis pas trop à
l'aise en ayant un casque ou des
écouteurs devenir parent avec des gens
alors ça reste quand même une fonction
qui est qui est très pratique lors des
gens qu'on peut venir customiser
directement à l'application vrai que ce
soit en termes de sensibilité de la
détection de la voix mais également le
temps d'attentes avant qu'il y avait de
la musique reprennent et qui peut être
très pratique on veut dire notamment
quand j'ai les mains prises par exemple
et que je peux pas du coup enlever le
casque ou les écouteurs de mes oreilles
et que je veux m'adresser à quelqu'un de
manière à de manière rapide c'est
quelque chose qui est qui sera utile
quand même d'accord tu utilises toi
personnellement non ah bon je suis pas
le seul attention parce que si vous
persistez truc comme ça va se faire
taper dessus mais en tout cas c'est une
fausse qualité qui sait je pense que
c'est une question de région je pense
que c'est une question peut-être de
culture ou est-ce que les usages revenir
évoluer là dessus c'est surtout une
question des usages selon les goûts de
chacun
ouais c'est ce que va permettre du coup
l'application en fonction de nos
préférences on va pouvoir venir
régler ce faire une utilisation sur
mesure en tout cas on peut le faire ça
c'est bien alors on peut continuer sur
l'api si c'est possible je vois compte
c'est déconnecté en reposant ses
critiques à l'égard des deux pas même
temps j'en ai conscience
alors on revient sur des qu'on regarde
un peu la partie et coalisation parce
que pour moi c'est un plan qui est
extrêmement important d'avoir une bonne
qualité audio c'est génial mais des fois
on a envie de venir personnaliser un
petit peu en fonction du style de
musique on a envie d'écouter sur une
écoute du jazz du rnb du hip hop ou si
on écoute de l'ultra techno hardcore n'a
pas forcément envie d'avoir la même et
colonisation et ici on peut vraiment
venir de paramétrer ça c'est vraiment
vraiment gêner un ciré effectivement et
la partie égalisation on va venir on va
pouvoir régler selon les différentes
ambiances
on a également ici voilà le l'égaliseur
cinq bandes qui permet vraiment de
travail et donc sur la qualité de son
est ce qu'on veut vraiment ce qu'on veut
vraiment écouter juste en dessous on a
également les je dirais les modes de
priorisation de la connexion bluetooth
soit on cherche une connexion bluetooth
qui est stable soit on va prioriser la
qualité de la qualité de son oui donc
élargir la bande passante professeur
faire passer beaucoup plus de données y
avoir une meilleure qualité de son de
son à la fin ok et puis on a une partie
système sur le haut exactement
alors je reviens hockey est donc là on
va pouvoir paramétrer l'assistant vocal
de préférence alors parlons-en de
l'assistant vocal parce que ça
m'intéresse l'assistant vocal donc ici
on va retrouver un peu tout le monde
google assistant ouais donc le produit
est optimisé donc pour
pour l'assistant google pour amazon et
alexa il est compatible également avec
siri donc c'est ça va être vraiment très
pratique au quotidien ce qu'on va
pouvoir demander
on va pour demander par exemple la météo
le qui fait par exemple anne itinéraire
ce genre de choses sans avoir besoin de
prendre son téléphone dans la main ou
même de toucher les écouteurs parce
qu'ils réagissent à la voix donc c'est
quelque chose de très pratique et ça
fait vraiment du de ces écouteurs un
assistant en fait au quotidien
ok et alors rien d'opaque il vraiment
vraiment super intéressant c'est toute
la partie justement de la configuration
des des capteurs tactiles comptable ça
pavé tactile qui est un tactile ouais ce
sont ceux sont les zones de commandes
tactiles hockey à la fois à gauche et à
droite
donc on va pouvoir venir on a par
exemple un récapitulatif des différentes
manipulations à la fois à gauche à la
fois à gauche et à droite
ouais on va pouvoir gérer donc sa
musique lecture pause suivant précédent
qu'avec une table de top ou 3 tab 1
appuyons également ça c'est notamment
pour la partie la partie musique qui se
retrouvent sur sur la droite à gauche on
va pouvoir gérer la réduction de bruit
par exemple donc l'activé la désactiver
ce genre de choses donc ça c'est
vachement pratique en fait parce qu'en
termes d'expérience tu prend l'habitude
de fétuque halte aux réglages comme toi
tu aimes tu prend l'habitude et c'est
vrai que c'est extrêmement intuitif et
ça marche pas très bien plus on a une
grande zone quand même regarder si vous
le voyez bien là la zone et hypra grande
donc vous pouvez pas vous tromper votre
doigt c'est que j'allais dire ça aussi
c'est un vrai point d'amélioration par
rapport au double ce mix martroi parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a tellement réduits en
fait l'encombrement du des écouteurs que
la seule presque 100% tepa 100% mais une
grande partie de la surface visible et
la surface tactile donc ce qui fait
quand on va toucher le produit on va
forcément donc toucher cette zone
tactile et donc ça tombe facilement sous
le doigt pour venir piloter voilà la
musique les appels on peut pas se
tromper
voilà exactement et ça c'est bien alors
je voudrais qu'on parle de l'autonomie
parce que là aussi on annonce des
chiffres qui sont vraiment vraiment cool
24 heures d'autonomie alors avec le
boîtier bien évidemment venir charger
c'est pas 24 heures avec le passé 24
heures avec la réduction de bruit active
active et et trente six heures sans la
réduction de bruit active voire
effectivement donc bon juste pour
revenir sur la dernière partie fait si
d'aventuré on venait à ne pas utiliser
la réduction peut effectivement on peut
monter à 30 6 heures 12 heures dans les
écouteurs ce qui est assez assez
colossal
plus deux fois douze heures dans le
boîtier maintenant si on vient à
utiliser réduction brise qui est quand
même la vocation première de ce produit
on a huit heures d'autonomie dans les
écouteurs soit deux ans de plus que les
doublettes mixtes mark iii et ce qui en
fait je dirais les champions de la
catégorie 1 parce que huit heures avec
la réduction de bruit et avec une grosse
qualité de son forcément c'est
énergivores et donc c'était un c'était
un beau pari est un pari dont qui est
qui est tenu et donc 8h + 3 x 8 heures
dans dans le boîtier de recherche qu'on
a juste à côté un boîtier qui est
compatible notamment avec la charge sans
fil ouais induction quid donc on vient
poser directement sur un sur les tapis
compatibles les zones compatibles et ça
va donc recharger sans fil donc ça c'est
quelque chose de très pratique et puis
si vous veniez à manquer de batterie
juste avant de prendre un train par
exemple vous n'avez pas pensé à le
recharger il ya une fonction charge
rapide qui est qui est disponible et
avec cinq minutes de charge on va
retrouver une heure de lecture donc
c'est vraiment vraiment très pratique
voilà en dernière minute ça c'est génial
on ait une différence de 2 de rapidité
de charges entre je vois que je switche
là entre ici l'usbc et la charge puis ça
va plus vite en usb sait où pousse est
sensiblement la même chose
pas à ma connaissance d'accord ok ok pas
de grande différence là dessus ok alors
il ya d'autres qui arrivent et qui est
super sympa ce qu'on appelle le google
fasse perd alors le google fasse peur
c'est une fonctionnalité qui va être
vraiment très pratique au quotidien qui
va faciliter en fait l'appairage des
écouteurs avec le téléphone
c'est dire qu'on aura juste besoin de
sortir les écouteurs du boîtier hockey
est tout de suite je vends une petite
fenêtre qui va sur les notamment donc
les smartphones android un pop up sur le
sur l'écran qui va nous proposer donc
d'appairer le d'appairer le produit de
manière très simple
donc on n'a plus besoin d'aller dans les
paramètres du téléphone chercher où ils
bluetooth et cetera chercher à présent
dans toutes les listes de produits qu'on
a ou qui sont visibles autour le nom du
produit en l'occurrence ça va se faire
de manière très très intuitive on va
pouvoir également aussi localiser
les écouteurs ça c'est une
fonctionnalité aussi qui est très
pratique avec l'écosystème l'écosystème
android rome va pouvoir donc le
localiser faire sonner manière
indépendante à gauche ou à droite les
écouteurs si jamais on les a égaré par
exemple un écouteur a glissé dans le
canapé dans le canapé par exemple soleil
donc voilà je vais pouvoir le faire le
faire sonner pour le retrouver de
manière très simple ça c'est pour la
partie
typiquement smartphones on a également
microsoft swiss perd donc celle à peu
près la même chose mais pour l'appairage
avec un avec un ordinateur
on va voir du coup la petite fenêtre en
bas à droite de l'écran qui va qui va
s'afficher et qui va proposer manière
très simple de
devenir connecter les écouteurs au pc ce
qui est vraiment très pratique surtout à
l'air aujourd'hui où on a beaucoup de
personnes qui sont en télétravail qui
fondent et qui font des réunions vial
des réunions en ligne et qui ont souvent
besoin de s'isoler chez eux pour être
tranquille et puis de communiquer
clairement avec avec leur équipe
voilà très pratique d'avoir d'avoir ce
produit avec soin on voit que ça permet
d'augmenter l'expérience on voit que
l'expérience globale avec notamment
cette collection plus rapide au niveau
de l'écosystème google et de microsoft
ça maximise totalement ça on avait déjà
une très belle expérience au niveau de
l'application ou vient aller encore plus
loin on élimine j'irai des petites des
petits des petits moments où on se dit à
sanaa un petit peu de temps à se
connecter
du coup on prend on ouvre on le met on a
accès à une expérience globale qui est
vraiment bien très bonne réduction de
bruit super qualité audio est une super
expérience au niveau de l'application
tout à fait tout est fait pour que pour
que l'expérience soit soit un titre
intuitive elle soit facile au quotidien
et voilà pour qu'on ait envie de
l'emporter les écouteurs partout avec
soi tout au long de la journée
que ce soit dans les transports et donc
ne pas écouter le bruit par exemple
quand on est dans le dans le métro dans
le bus ou dans l'eau dans le train les
avoir avec ça pendant qu'au bureau pour
travailler
grâce au kit mains libres qui est qui a
intégré je pense qu'on en veut alors mr
ce genr c'est pour la transition ça
c'est parfait d'y arriver et pour
terminer et pour terminer ce que voit le
produit extrêmement polyvalent
il va pourra également vous accompagner
durant nos séances de sport ou m à
l'extérieur parce qu'il est certifié et
px cas donc c'est à dire qu'il va
résister à la pluie et la transpiration
à la sueur
donc voilà on a un très bon fit donc
très bonne stabilité dans l'oreille et
une résistance donc à l'humidité
donc voilà je pourrais aller courir la
salle de sport avec on a vraiment un
produit qui nous accompagne tout au long
de la journée ça c'est un produit qui
peut prendre du matin alors matin ce
n'était pas toute la journée parce que
moi il faut faire laisser un peu
respirer ses oreilles mais en fait il
peut nous accompagner sans aucun
problème on sait qu'il sera résistant
qu'on rencontre un petit peu d'eau qu'on
transpire office ou ci ou ça ça ira
et ça fonctionnera bien tout à fait ça
c'est bien alors tu m'a lancé la perche
il ya un truc qu'on peut faire avec ses
écouteurs et qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est fait passer un coup de
fil ça peut paraître anodin mais c'est
vrai que pour optimiser tout ça et bien
il y encore les technologies derrière et
alors notamment julie intentions kit
mains libres à faissault acoustique et
capteurs de conduction osseuse c'est
vrai que derrière ce derrière ce produit
il y a plusieurs usages le premier va
être forcément la musique est également
tout ce qu'on va aussi écouter quand il
n'ya pas donc ddd films en streaming
genre de choses sur notre smartphone
et puis également toute la partie et
qualité d'appel sur les appels
téléphoniques des appels quand on est en
visio aujourd'hui pendant que le
télétravail beaucoup et donc c'est vrai
que à ce niveau là il ya tout un travail
qui a été fait au niveau des écouteurs
avec différents micros qui vont venir
vont capter uniquement le son de la voix
de la personne qui l'utilisé et non pas
tout ce qui à tout ce qui entoure donc
il va venir
isolé le son de la voix afin par exemple
tu m'entends très bien quand on quand on
s'appelle par exemple la chanson vient
tout de suite à côté de moi donc il ya
des micros on a également ajouté à un
capteur de conduction osseuse oui donc
ça c'est aussi une première sur sur ces
produits là donc l'idée avec ce capteur
c'est qu'il va venir détecter quand
est-ce que tu bouche là
la mâchoire toqué je parle et donc il va
tout de suite comprendre que c'est là
c'est ta voix et non pas les bruits
autour qu'on doit venir isolés et
retransmettre à l'interlocuteur ça c'est
purement mécanique en fait exactement
j'aime bien l'octavia convient à lier la
mécanique à l'électronique pour
optimiser la keynote cour d appel
derrière donc un algorithme qui va venir
remettre tout sort en harmonie les
micros le
le capteur de conduction osseuse pour
avoir des appels très clair voilà
l'origine question aujourd'hui ni
intention c'est une question 5000 à 6000
points
quand on va toutes les technologies
qu'on a ici quand on voit ce que vous
avez fait comment vous avez intégré ce
produit qu'est ce qui vous reste comme
marge de manoeuvre pour venir proposer
un mix n 5
il arrivera un jour où l'autre jr je te
fais le parallèle par rapport à ce que
je vois dans le chat et merci à vous
d'être nombreux et nombreuses de nous
poser des questions on nous demande
aujourd'hui quels sont les défauts
quelles sont les faiblesses
il ya toujours des faiblesses sur des
défauts c'est vrai que ce produit moi
j'aime beaucoup je l' ai testé pendant
un petit moment
je trouve extrêmement performant la
réduction brute et hop est-ce qu'on peut
encore améliorer la réduction de bruit
pour ne vraiment rien entendre du tout
on voit quatre petites fréquence qui
passe souvent dans les médiums
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer venir
améliorer parce que moi se produit
aujourd'hui extrêmement complet quelles
peuvent être les côtés un peu négatif
c'est important de venir faire aussi 7,1
s'est passée cette confession mais
qu'est ce qu'elles sont les limites de
ce produit je pense qu'aujourd'hui on a
vraiment un produit qui est radicalement
différent de ce qu'on avait sur la
précédente génération entre un double
less unix martroi et un wf 1000 x mark
iv et il ya vraiment un gros travail qui
a été fait soit pour gommer les défauts
du la précédente génération soit pour se
mettre à niveau par rapport à ce qui
pouvait se faire aussi sur le marché ce
qu'on a il s'est passé deux ans entre
entre les générations et il ya un gros
travail qui a été fait par par les
ingénieurs
aujourd'hui on se parle de 40 %
d'amélioration de la réduction de bruit
entre les deux les deux générations donc
ça c'est pas anodin et je pense que
voilà c'est déjà un gros un gros pas en
avant les qualités de son là on les dit
tout à l'heure elle également qui fait
un pas qui fait un pas en avant donc
typiquement aujourd'hui on vient coché
toutes les cases qui qui pouvait encore
manquer sur le double effet mix marque 3
et donc on vient proposer ici et que le
avec le mark être hyper cool alors je te
remercie beaucoup c'est un produit que
je vous le dis une fois de plus si vous
intéresse vous trouvez les liens si vous
êtes sur le site de la fnac en train de
nous regarder
eh bien vous avez les produits à côté
pour venir cliquer et commander le vote
pour vous faire plaisir au choix vous
avez de couleur vous avez co comment
s'appelle cette couleur c'est le donc à
cinq coloris argent argent et un coloris
noir ou noir mat est ici donc voilà
argent pareil une finition mate qui fait
très très haut de gamme avec des petits
sincère du coup doré au niveau du micro
extérieur
ouais on retrouve également sur sur le
boîtier hyper sympa très compacte ok
donc ça c'est top
le prix on me le demande dans le chat
joue le redonne ses 279 euros pour être
extrêmement précis c'est un certain
budget mais on est dans l'ultra premium
haut niveau de l'audio et surtout au
niveau de la réduction de bruit
merci jean denis est ce que tu vois
quelque chose à rajouter qu'on n'aurait
pas dit un truc qu'on aurait omis qu'on
aurait oublié lors de la préparation et
qui nous viendrait comme une évidence
qu'il faut dire tout de suite je pense
qu'on a déjà couvert pas mal de sujets
et encore on pourrais je pense passer
encore du temps dessus a évoqué encore
toutes les facettes les facettes du
produit mais non c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui on a un produit qui est
qui est extrêmement complet et qui va
répondre vraiment au maximum de besoins
qu'on peut avoir tous les jours l'idée
étant d'avoir un produit résolument haut
de gamme ultra performant sur la
réduction de bruit la qualité de son
mais également un produit qui soit
polyvalent qui soit vraiment un
assistant au quotidien on a vu les
assistants vocaux on a vu la partie
appels téléphoniques la résistance la
résistance à l'eau une grande autonomie
on prêtait de rajouter un petit point
sur la partie connexion bluetooth qu'on
n'a pas évoqué donc ici on est sur du
5.2 c'est à dire qu'on va avoir une
connexion à la fois à gauche et à droite
vraiment distinctes qui va également
permettre un usage soit de l'écouteur
gauche au de l'écouteur droit donc ici
on n'a pas d'écouteurs m et des couteaux
en éclats avec notamment un flux qui
passe au niveau de la tête donc là on
laisse le vote est tranquille et se
savait de manière directe le flux de
transmission de données se fait
d'ailleurs direct entre les écouteurs
manière individuelle jusqu'au jusqu'au
téléphone
donc ça ça permet notamment d'éviter les
problèmes de latence donc le décalage
que vous pouvez avoir des fois entre le
son et l'image qu'on voit départ non
plus une vidéo avec votre votre
téléphone
les problèmes des petits problèmes de
coupures qui peut y avoir sur ce type de
produits sur le marché et ça permet
également d'économiser de la batterie
well coup les écouteurs ont une seule
fonction de réception du signal et non
plus émission réception dans leur
architecture plus plus anciennes genre
lydia hockey effectivement ce que ça
permet de faire également sait si on
vous dit je veux passer un coup de fil
avec l'écouteur gauche ou aurait
d'écouteurs droit je peux changer pour
exact c'est très pratique exactement
très pratique quelques petites questions
dans le chat pour terminer on nous
demande
et sinon avec le firmware on peut
imaginer le à ptx intégrer c'est des
choses qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui qu'on
trouve pas du rap et eric si vous est-ce
que c'est des choses qu'on pourrait
imaginer au dans une version au futur
alors aujourd'hui fait donc tout à
l'heure le mentionner les codecs
embarqués sont là assez le sbc des
codecs très traditionnel ouais et
aujourd'hui donc la vocation de ce
modèle est avant tout donc de proposer
un son haute résolution et donc voilà
certifié à iraizoz diaw wireless on l'a
dit tout à l'heure
et aujourd'hui c'est le lda qui va nous
permettre d'avoir d'avoir cette
certification l'a7 ce niveau de qualité
de son top j'ai compris bonsoir nous
d'ikea haut pour la qualité des micro
lors des appels ça donne quoi alors le
mieux c'est de tester par vous même donc
si vous intéresse le lien sont en bas
mais toi qui l'a testé
qu'est ce que tu en penses au niveau de
la qualité des appels au niveau des
micro est ce que ça fonctionne bien
c'est fidèles par rapport à un génie oui
mais je l'avis d'experts c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu un gros travail de fait par
rapport aux doubles fmx martroi que ce
soit d'un point de vue micro ajout de la
conduction de la conduction osseuse
également l'algorithme derrière qui
vient travailler sur ces micro qui vient
vraiment isolé la voix de la personne
voilà qui parle donc effectivement il ya
un gros pas en avant qui est fait entre
les entre les deux générations
et puis à côté de ça on va également
avoir la réduction de bruit alors on l'a
pas mentionné mais qui va aussi jouer
jouer son rôle en permettant vous deux
vous isolez d'être bien concentré sur
votre discussion
donc ça c'est vraiment très agréable
après quand vous discutez avec avec
quelqu'un top écoute jean denis je teins
merci beaucoup merci pour toutes ces
précisions c'est très complet on a tenu
quarante trois minutes c'est vous dire
qu'il ya tellement de choses à raconter
on pourrait encore faire plus mais à un
moment il faut aller se coucher pas pas
encore mais allez manger peut-être en
tout cas merci à vous d'avoir été
extrêmement présents nombreux nombreuses
que ce soit sur le site de la fnac que
ce soit sur ma chaîne youtube
pourparlers pour tout savoir pour venir
conversé au sujet de ces nouveaux sony
wf mille lixheim quatre super
intéressant et je les y arrive
ingénieusement vraiment super produit
hyper hyper canon donc si vous voulez
des très très joli produit qu'on vous
faire plaisir vous voulez des baux intra
que vous avez un budget de 279 euros
et bien vous pouvez y aller les yeux
fermés ce sont vraiment des très très
très joli produit est là dessus sans os
qui montre absolument vous ne vous ne
vous pouvez pas vous tromper sans super
as un truc hyper hyper calme voilà merci
beaucoup
jean denis merci à toi merci pour
l'accueil merci pour les questions aussi
un des personnes et puis au plaisir de
retrouver une prochaine fois pour
continuer à parler de sony alors sony on
en reparlera sur ma chaîne youtube pour
parler de smartphones parce que ça
arrive avec les nouveaux xperia
c'est une autre histoire merci à vous
d'avoir été nombreux nombreuses et puis
à très bientôt sur le jean denis merci a
bientot prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt caoutchouc
[Musique]
oh